hier gibt einen vogel strauß richtig gas
mitten in china wächst dieser strauß
während der fahrt von einem anhänger aus
und gibt knie gas linke spur rechte spur
und das immer ohne zu blinken die
anderen autofahrer staunen nicht
schlecht fahren in gebührendem abstand
hinterher versuchen das tier mit der
hupe zu verscheuchen
südlich von peking in tianjin kommt es
zu diesem kuriosen vorfall der vogel
strauß kann schließlich eingefangen und
seinem besitzer wieder unverletzt
übergeben werden strauße können nicht
fliegen aber bis zu 70 km h schnell
werden ob dieser vogel strauß auf der
autobahn in china geblitzt wurde ist
nicht bekannt